[Applaudissements]
je vais vous raconter une histoire mais
je ne sais pas si elle se termine bien
mais je sais qu'elle est là et qu'elle
va changer ma vie tout d'abord pour se
remettre dans le contexte je suis
architecte designer je passe mon temps à
chercher et à trouver des solutions
esthétique fonctionnel de jetair tout a
commencé par une prise de conscience ça
ne s'est pas fait comme ça du jour au
lendemain je ne suis pas réveillé un
matin en me disant eurêka non non ça
s'est fait petit à petit et c'est une
soirée qui a enfoncé le clou avec nico
mon mari associés parmi vous dans la
salle nous nous sommes rendus dans un
lieu dans lequel on mélange l'art et
l'urbanisme ce lieu s'appelle le polo le
pôle d'arts urbains dans ce lieu nous
étions invités pour participer une
exposition qui traitait le sujet comment
faire de l' architecture de manière plus
écologique
le but étant d'avoir des échanges avec
le public pour réfléchir à la question
je me souviens très bien que nous sommes
entrés dans l'entrée il y avait plein de
panneaux d'affichage qui nous
indiquaient un certain nombre
d'informations sur la fin des ressources
planétaires ressources planétaires comme
le zinc le cuivre le fer
tout cela nous indiquait que ces
ressources étaient voie de la
disparition d'ici très peu de temps
alors ok on sait tous très peu de temps
mais ce qu'on sait pas c'est que très
peu de temps c'est demain prenons
l'exemple du zinc
vous savez ce matériau qui recouvre tous
les toits de paris ce matériau qui
recouvre les comptoir de bar pour ceux à
qui ça parle plus eh bien ces matériaux
à l'échelle mondiale en 2025
c'est à dire dans six ans on en a plus
demain quoi
et savez vous que dans le même sens
l'exploitation inexorable du béton
l'utilisation autant pour moi inexorable
du béton menacent environ 90% de nos
plages dans le monde
en effet l'utilisation du béton
je suis désolé pour utiliser du béton il
faut utiliser une certaine quantité de
sable pour donner un exemple pour
construire un kilomètre d'autoroute
il faut trente mille tonnes de béton
trente mille tonnes de béton c'est
environ 10 mille tonnes de sable un
petit kilomètre d'autoroute une centrale
nucléaire c'est 12 millions de tonnes de
béton 4 millions de tonnes de sable à
l'échelle mondiale on extrait de nos
plages et de nos fonds marins 15
milliards de tonnes de sable pour plus
marqué vos esprits le sable et la
deuxième ressource la plus consommée
dans le monde après l'eau l'eau le sable
dans ce sens le mur en parpaings que
vous connaissez bien sera devenu
inconstructible dans 20 ans le bâtiment
dans lequel nous nous trouvons ne pourra
plus être fabriquée comme aujourd'hui
alors cet impact certes l'exploitation
du sable a un impact sur le béton mais
pas seulement
il s'agit aussi de nos îles en effet
beaucoup de villes sont voués à
disparaître des îles qui permettent à
l'homme ou à des animaux de vivre 25
qu'il indonésiennes ont déjà disparu
c'est aussi l'obligation pour des
familles de quitter leur foyer de migrer
c'est la modification drastique
d'écosystèmes qui impacte le
réchauffement climatique tout est lié
comment en est on arrivé là pourquoi
leurs ressources disparaissent elles
aussi vite
j'ai un élément de réponse à ces
questions le secteur du bâtiment est le
premier créateur de déchets en volume
prenons l'exemple du fer le faire qui
est un élément primordial dans la
construction de dans les constructions
actuelles le faire chaque chaque année
nous en jetons l'équivalent d'environ
500 tour eiffel jeudi 500 tour eiffel
par an
autant pour moi
par jour 7 200 milles tour eiffel qui
sont jetés à la poubelle chaque année
pour mieux vous représentez c'est comme
si on recouvrait chaque année 28 fois la
surface de paris qu'on mettait tout à la
poubelle
vous imaginez alors revenons à nos
moutons
je suis dans le hall du pôle eau je vois
tous ces panneaux indicatifs qui me
renvoie la disparition de toutes ces
matières premières ça me renvoie
nécessairement à mon métier
moi j'ai un rôle à jouer dans tout ça je
n'ai pas simplement un simple conseil
ma mission en tant qu architecte en tant
que créateur en tant que concepteur
c'est de participer à l'annulation à
l'inversion de cette tendance
tout ça est un comme un électrochoc
c'est une seconde naissance dans mon
travail alors deux choix s'offrent à moi
soit je fait l'autruche
j'attends quelqu'un se bouge pour suivre
la mouvance soit je me bouge je fais
quelque chose je cherche des solutions
et vous imaginez bien que c'est la
seconde option est choisie dans ce sens
j'ai cherché il existe énormément de
solutions dans le domaine de
l'architecturé pourquoi ne pas les les
valoriser je vais vous proposer
d'étudier trois tendances trois options
possibles trois directions pour essayer
d'étayer ses solutions dans un premier
temps il y a le bon sens et oui le bon
sens par exemple ce parpaings que l'on
connaît on peut le remplacer par un
matériau simple fonctionnel la brique en
terre cuite la brique en terre cuite
nous africains terre cuite est un
matériau local on peut la broyé on peut
la réutiliser la re transformer en
briques
c'est un matériau durable on peut aussi
analyser le terrain l'environnement dans
lequel on se trouve
en effet on n'ouvre pas pleinement est
dans certains secteurs
au risque d'être à la merci de
bourrasques et d'infiltration on ne fait
pas une grande baie vitrée plein sud si
on habite à nice quel enfer il faut
souvent regarder comment on faisait
avant
nos anciens savaient intelligemment
observer leur environnement prendre le
temps de comprendre le vent
le soleil les matériaux ensuite en
seconde option il y à l'innovation
bien entendu prenons le bois le bois est
un matériau qui a toutes les qualités
dans la construction
l'innovation l'ua nous permet
aujourd'hui de construire des bâtiments
bien plus grand qu'il ne l'était le bois
a été remplacé par le fer et le béton
dans le 19ème siècle c'était
l'innovation depuis cette situation sur
les ressources nous permet de rebondir
et grâce aux nouvelles technologies
aujourd'hui les fournisseurs de bois
les artisans du bois ont à leur
disposition un maximum de produits nous
avons les poutres en i les panneaux
sandwich les contrecollé les lamellé
collé qui nous permette de grande portée
alors je vous vois venir
le bois c'est pas solide ça brûle ça
pourri mais dans les cathédrales qu'on
connaît si bien
c'est les pierres qu'on change avant la
charpente
s'il ya un incendie le pompier vous
préconisera d'abord une poutre en bois
avant une poutre en fer qui va fondre
enfin le bois est un matériau de
prédilection pour une maison écologique
un bâtiment écologique en effet le
boivin de l'arbre que l'on peut
replanter c'est donc un matériau durable
à condition d'en prendre soin car la
déforestation n'est pas lié à la
construction en bois
la déforestation est liée à l'extension
des zones agricoles en plantes toujours
plus de maïs de soja pour nourrir le
bétail en plantes de la palme pour avoir
une matière grasse pas cher mais
rassurez-vous en france nous avons un
patrimoine ford un patrimoine forestier
formidable pour construire en bois en
troisième solution que je vous propose
il y a le biomimétisme idrissa berkane
qui est un essayiste est un grand
habitué des tedx nous vanter les
qualités que l'on peut retrouver autour
de nous tout est à notre disposition il
faut observer
gunter pauli qui est économiste de
l'écologie et qui a écrit un livre qui
s'appelle l'économie bleus relate dans
son livre que la technologie
d'aujourd'hui doit être remplacé
la physique la logique doit revenir au
coeur de nos constructions
en effet on croit en nos maisons de plus
en plus hermétique pour des pour des
questions d pour des questions de
parents - d'isolation une maison
hermétique
c'est l'accumulation de l'humidité par
conséquent on installe des systèmes
ultra performant pour ventiler nos
maisons on règle un problème qui
n'existait pas auparavant
de plus ces maisons hermétique créé une
accumulation de poussière une
prolifération des acariens qui accentue
les maladies respiratoires telles que
l'asthme ou la bronchiolite de plus en
plus présente chez les nourrissons pour
revenir à gunter pauli à son étude est
son analyse de la nature on peut prendre
comme exemple les termites la thermite
est un animal qui a plus de 100 millions
d'années la thermite est capable dans
son habitat de gérer l'humidité la
température la pression atmosphérique
rien que par la forme de son habitat
de plus elle est capable de choisir des
zones qu'elle voudra humide pour
produire son aliment de base le
champignon grâce à la thermite on
pourrait apprendre à climatiser sans
polluer prenons maintenant le zèbre le
zébra des rayures blanches et noires
comme tout le monde le sait et grâce à
cela il est en mesure de réduire la
température de son corps de dix degrés
au dessus des rayures blanches l'air est
frais au dessus des rues noires des
rayures noires l'air est plus chaud cela
crée des microsystèmes de courant d'air
qui ventile sa peau incroyable et une
bonne solution en amenant une autre
les moustiques ne lui pique pas ils sont
gênés par les courants d'air sur cet
exemple au zimbabwe à harare
un bâtiment a été construit reprenant le
système de ventilation des termitières
et le système de rafraîchissement des
amants ils ont rayé toute la toiture et
ils ont créé une façade avec un dessin
et un graphisme reprenant les rayures du
zèbre
il s'agit donc d'observer d'analyser de
s'adapter à son environnement et
d'innover alors bien sûr j'ai essayé
d'intégrer tous ses élus
dans mon travail au quotidien mais ce
n'est pas toujours facile on est
contraint par un budget une assurance
frileuse voir un client qui n'est pas
forcément prêt avec le premier à mettre
en place une méthode
les banques ne nous facilite pas
toujours la tâche financer un projet
alternatif n'est pas toujours dans leurs
priorités
on connaît aussi notre société ses
dérives ses limites et surtout le peu de
temps qu'il nous reste c'est dans ce
contexte que mon histoire continue car
c'est dans ce contexte que j'ai décidé
de devenir artiste en 2017 avec nico
nous nous sommes inscrits au festival
des jardins de chaumont-sur-loire pas
loin d'ici
un festival dédié au jardin alors nous
on n'était pas du tout de la partie
paysages on en avait jamais fait mais
c'était l'occasion de s'exprimer
eh bien figurez-vous qu'on a été
sélectionné tout content qu'on ait ont
créé un projet dans lequel on met la
fleur en exergue au coeur d'un écrin de
miroirs l'idée étant que cette fleur
aussi belle soit elle aussi fragile ne
doit pas être demain le jardin
privilégié d'une élite
eh ben on a eu le prix de la création
content comme comme pas deux on se dit
banco
on fera de l'art c'est comme ça que j'ai
décidé de devenir artiste
juste pour ne pas rester inactive alors
depuis ont fait de nombreux projets pour
montrer comme le monde est beau comme il
faut le préserver aussi naïf que sa part
est que ça paraisse
on ne ne cessera jamais de le répéter
c'est comme ça que je suis devenu
artiste pour ne pas rester inactive de
cause à effet je deviens artistes
merci
[Applaudissements]